نصيحه ذهبيه لتحسين الصحه واللياقه
البدنيه والاهم دون تمارين حقيقيه هذا من
الممكن طبعا وهذه عبر دراسه امريكيه وجدت
ان اضافه ما وصفته بالاطعمه الخارقه
للنظام الغذائي يعادل المشي 4000 خطوه
اضافيه في اليوم الدراسه اجريت على اكثر
من 2000 شخص اخذت في الاعتبار مستويات
النشاط البدني حتى بين الرياضيين انفسهم
النتائج اكدت الارتباط القوي بين النمط
الغذائي وتحسن اللياقه البدنيه وارجحت
السبب الى ان الانظمه الصحيه تساعد الجسم
على حرق اكثر لسعرات الحراريه اضافه ايضا
الى تقليل
من الاصابه بامراض القلب والسرطان
دراسات كثيره ولكن بالفعل هناك اطعمه
خارقه تساعدنا يعني ما نمارس رياضه ونروح
لهذه الاطعمه والله هلا اشوف هلا مجرد
احنا قلنا دراسه معناتها هذا الشيء صار
وصار على اشخاص لحتى هني توصلوا لهي
النتيجه هلا في شغله دائما نحن في توازن
بين كل شيء يعني هلا انت بتعرف احنا
لنحافظ على جسم صحي لازم يكون الداخل مثل
الخارج يعني على كميه الاكل اللي عملناها
لازم يكون في حرق لهي السعرات تمام اذا
بنحافظ على وزننا الداخل قد الخارج يعني
العمل ناكله قد اللي نحن الحرق اللي عم
نحرقه اذا كنا بدنا ننزل وزنها لازم ناكل
اخف من كميه الحرق اللي عم بتصير اكيد في
اطعمه مثل
الفواكه الحمضيه مثل التوت مثل البرتقان
الجريب فروت الليمون هذا فيهم الاحماض
الالفا
هذه بتساعد اي تماما هاي بتساعد على حرق
الده في عنا الاسماك الدهنيه هاي فيها
الاوميجا 3 اللي كمان هي بتحفز وبتساعد
كمان على انه هي ترفع وتعزز معدل الايض
ومن هيك الدراسه عملها بتحكي عن انه اذا
بناكل هاي الاطعمه بنقدر نقلل من العمل
البدني او الجهد البدني ممكن نوصل لانه هي
بتساعد على حرق تساعد على حرق الدهون
بالجسم اعطينا هيك ليست او يعني شيء مفصل
ممكن المشاهدين واحنا نستفيد منه بانه اذا
بناكل هاي هي السوبر فودز احنا بنحكي عن
السوبر فودز ما راح اكل غيرهم هلا طبعا
بالاكل مثل ما قلت لكم الفواكه الحمضيه
مهمه الخضار اللي فيها هي عباره عن اوراق
خضراء مثل
السبانخ مثل الكرنب في عنا كمان الخضروات
بكل انواعها المكسرات والبذور في عندنا
المكسرات
كثير مهمين كمان انه كمان بيساعد على
امتصاص الدهون الجسم في عنا الكركم كركم
هذا اذا غليناه وشربناه هذا بيمنع تراكم
الدهون بالجسم وبنفس الوقت بيس حب الدسم
من الجسم لما بناكل شيء دسم
[موسيقى]